[Music]
attention all proud warriors have you
ever considered joining time patrol as a
time patroller you'll prevent history
from being changed our duty is to
protect everyone's memories and help
return history to the way it should be
we've got a school for honing your
skills and a fully equipped item shop we
look forward to welcoming each of you in
a time patrol
oh come on
why bother anyway they're wreaking havoc
throughout history well enough on their
own
[Music]
you want to come with me
how
missions for you when you get back okay
My partner is currently in route to your
location I want you to try and kill me
nothing left
the Dragonball timeline has been
threatened once more and it's your
mission to protect it a world of fierce
battles await you as you enter a
different dimension to keep history from
falling apart
[Music]
shaving off life to unleash a new level
of power this
it's a formidable power something's
coming on you're gone the only way to
confront the new threat is to join
forces use the unique powers of your
allies to your advantage
but be careful as they may be turned
against you this new dimension is
dangerous and unpredictable and the best
way to survive is as a team amazing what
power it's up to me
we'll change the future
allow me to continue my vengeance
listen I know how to be rid of you now
don't wait any longer it's time to fight
alongside those heroes with your own
power and with your allies throughout
the world
Dragonball xenoverse 2
this is the moment I've been waiting for
you
[Music]